It's cool that we learned how to use the console to manipulate other web pages,
but, of course, we need to start making our own.
>> It's easy to open up the page.
I'm going to get rid of this Hello World here.
And all you have to do is open index.html in the browser of your choice,
like we have here.
And refresh the page.
And you'll see a very exciting blank page.
Let's talk about how we're going to write something here on this page.
>> It's not too hard.
We can use jQuery's .append function to add HTML to an element on the page.
>> And if the element already has some HTML content,
a pen will add the new HTML to the end of the old content.
>> Yeah.
I have got ResumeBuilder.js open here.
For our website, we wanted to append HTML to the page's Header.
We will start with this jQuery selector for Header.
The pound sign tells us that we're looking for an element with the id of header.
So in our HTML, we see this div with id equals header.
This selector grabs this tag.
Let's give our students a chance to try it out.